[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANUEL AMUNATEGUI:
Hello, everybody.
Thank you for being here.
It's a pleasure.
Priya and I are
really excited to talk
smart case-routing
systems with you today.
It's a combination of some
of the better techniques
that we've encountered, the
better approaches, the best
tools, and also lessons
we've learned from building
case-routing systems and
natural language processing
through the years at SpringML.
Let me look at the agenda, here.
We're going to start by
introducing ourselves,
SpringML, and
case-routing-- briefly.
Then we're going to tackle
the meat of the matter--
the three main models that build
this smart case-routing system.
And finally, we'll
open up for questions.
And we'll also be
around afterwards
if you have
additional questions.
So let's present ourselves.
Do you want to start, Priya?
PRIYA DWIVEDI: Yeah, sure.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Priya Dwivedi.
I'm a data scientist
at SpringML.
I've been at SpringML
for about six months.
Prior to joining SpringML,
I worked for Capital One
for about 10 years.
I'm very passionate
about deep learning,
and I've been working through
it for the last three years.
I also write blogs
very frequently,
and you can find me on Medium.
MANUEL AMUNATEGUI: Thank you.
My name's Manuel Amunategui,
and I'm also a data scientist.
I'm the VP of Data
Science at SpringML,
and I've been at
SpringML practically
since the beginning--
I think a few months shy--
since the company was
created about three years ago.
Prior to that, I
was a data scientist
in health care for four years.
And prior to that, a
quantitative developer
on Wall Street for six years.
And I'm very passionate
and interested
about applied data science.
I like to see how we take
all these models that
are coming our way
every day, and see
how we can apply them to make
our everyday life easier,
right?
So of course, curing cancer
would be great, right?
But it's not an easy
thing to tackle.
But case-routing,
these kind of things--
we have the tools today to
do it and to do it well.
So this is very exciting.
So briefly about
SpringML, we're a company
that brings AI and machine
learning to companies
who either don't have the staff,
the department, the know-how,
or need extra hands.
And we will take a
step back with them,
look at what they're trying
to do, look at their data
if it can be achieved, and then
dive in with them as a team
so that we work in
tandem and that they
have a sense of ownership.
And then they can take it on.
They can extend it.
And they can sell it
internally if need be,
and we're also happy to form
longer-term relationships.
I mentioned that we build quite
a few case-routing systems,
and that's true.
Over the years,
we've built them.
And what's interesting
about case-routing--
and natural language
processing in general--
is that it has
evolved enormously.
What we're going
to present today
is very different
than where we started.
Actually, there's probably
very little that intersects.
And we've done a lot of
case-routing demos internally.
We've done them for
Google, and we've also
partnered with Google
for other customers.
The biggest customer
we've worked with is CBRE.
It's a very large commercial
real estate company.
They're all around
the world, and you
can imagine the flurries of
cases going back and forth--
issues, questions, comments.
So you could have, on one end--
please, in this country,
change a light bulb here.
There you can have, oh, there's
a great investment opportunity
there.
Or here, there's a
building that's flooded.
The basement is flooded.
We need to call the
maintenance crew.
So all these things
go back and forth.
This is a very large company.
So automating case-routing
for companies of that size--
but even smaller
companies-- is a huge win.
That's what we're going
to talk about today.
So that we're all on the same
page, what is case-routing?
So case-routing is whenever
you have a department, a team,
or even a single person
that is in charge
of taking either
external queries
or questions or internal
ones, and routing
them-- case-routing, right?
Routing them to where
they need to go.
In some cases, they can
even answer them, right?
And show of hands, who's
been on-call for their job?
Yeah.
I was on-call.
When I was in health
care, I was on-call,
and it was a really tough job.
Very stressful.
Because I remember,
health care never sleeps.
Machines go down on a
weekend or at night,
and I didn't know who to
turn to, where to get help.
The people I would
normally ask help,
they were either sleeping
or playing golf, right?
So it was very
stressful, and that's
why I have a personal agenda to
work on this to fix this issue.
And why would you
want to automate this?
Well, the obvious
reasons, right?
You're removing
that middle, layer--
the people on-call like me
who don't want to be on-call.
You're removing that.
And the customer or the
client or the employee
who has a question--
they know that's
going to go to the right
department immediately.
You get 24/7 support.
You can handle multiple
languages, right?
We modeled this in English, but
you could very well model it
in any language you want.
So once you have
one language down,
it's just a question of
getting enough historical data
to model other languages.
You can do Auto Reply, right?
Very simple Auto Reply.
Somebody's saying, when
is the office open?
And you say, oh, this country
has a national holiday.
Try this date, right?
These are easy wins.
You could automate that.
And more important, I think,
is a centralized digital trail.
You're going to start getting a
warehouse of all your queries,
all your questions.
So who's asking what
type of question?
Where are their problems?
What department
tackles those answers?
Which one are struggling
to answer those questions?
All that is gold for
a company, right?
You can really learn a
lot about your company,
about what's going
on with your costs,
and learning about
your customers as well.
So these are the
three main models
that we're going to talk about--
basically, the brains behind
what we're going to present.
There's going to be a
convolutional neural network
that's going to do
the predicting of what
department to route a case to.
There is the Google
Language API that we're
going to leverage as much
information as we can
from there to get
additional information.
And finally, finding
similar cases.
So you got a case that came in.
You want to know, what
is a similar case,
and how was it resolved?
That's great hints for somebody
who's handling the case load.
And as a high-level
architecture,
before we dive
into the CNNs, this
is what we build in the path.
This is what we would
build today, too.
You have the incoming
case that comes in,
and you have the App Engine.
So the App Engine is
a serverless instance
in the Cloud.
It's a great type of instance--
Compute Engine-- for
this type of project,
especially if you have
cyclical case loads, right?
So if you have more
cases during the year,
these things will size
automatically, will balance,
will scale.
And you pay only
for what you use.
It's also the choreographer,
the manager of the data.
It will do some data cleaning,
pass it to the Cloud MLE--
the mounted Machine Learning
Engine in the Cloud--
which is hosting our
convolutional neural network.
And Priya will talk
more about the data set,
but it's about financial
consumer complaints, right?
We're using an open
source data set,
and it can route it into
one of seven departments--
Consumer Loan, Vehicle Loan,
Bank Account, Student Loan,
Mortgage, Credit
Card, or Payday Loan.
So these departments
are all related
and all within the
financial industry.
And so the CNN will tell you
what department to route it to.
So now we know
where to route it.
The App Engine will then
also pass that information
to the Language API,
where we're going
to get all sorts of information
we can, like sentiment.
We'll know the tone of the case.
Things like the
organization it involves.
And now we can populate that
information in our case report.
And we're also going
to query BigQuery--
a huge, bottomless data
warehouse where, I was reading,
it could query 35 billion rows
in seconds, with no indexes.
So a very powerful tool.
Perfect for storing all of your
knowledge base, all your cases.
And here we're going
to pull similar cases.
And the end-product for the
demo is this smart report,
we call it, right?
So it will tell you what
the complaint is, give you
some hints about
what's going on there,
and some suggestions
of how to resolve it.
So this is for the demo, right?
Most of the cases, we
would feed this directly
to the customer's CRM, right?
They probably have
a tool already.
So either a rest point
or an API, right?
But for the sake of
the demo, we wanted
something that was visual.
And I'm going to pass
it to Priya, who's
going to talk about the CNNs.
PRIYA DWIVEDI: Thanks, Manuel.
So I'm going to talk about how
we build a Convolutional Neural
Network in TensorFlow
to do the case-routing.
So before I start,
by show of hands,
can I know how many of you
have built any kind of model
in TensorFlow before?
OK, that's a lot.
That's really good to know.
I've kept the talk
here high level,
but if you have any
specific questions,
feel free to stop
me after the talk.
So the first thing
I want to talk about
is the data set that we
use to build this model.
Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau in the US
has a publicly
available data set
of 274,000 consumer complaints
across many different products
like mortgage, credit cards,
student loans, et cetera.
When a consumer
complains to CFPB,
they have the option of
making their complaint public.
And when they decide to do that,
any sensitive information--
like their names or amounts
or dates-- are anonymous,
and this data is
publicly available.
We think this is a really good
data set for deep learning,
because it's pretty big.
There's a huge variety here.
It uses natural language.
And what I mean by
that is if you actually
read through the
complaints, you'll
see that some complaints
are very long.
Some are short.
There are spelling mistakes.
Some consumers
repeat themselves.
So it's perfect to use
that for deep learning.
I also feel that the database
is very rich in financial terms,
so it's possible to actually
use this dataset for other use
cases, like routing
customer service calls.
So now that we have
the dataset, you
can think of this dataset
as individual complaints,
and complaints can
be long or short.
So I've taken a
sample complaint here
that says, "You declined
my transaction when
I was shopping."
And this is all words,
but neural networks
love numbers and math, so we
do pre-processing that converts
these sentences into numbers.
The first thing we do
is we break the sentence
into individual words.
And so that would
be "You" "declined"
"my" "transaction," et cetera.
And then we map these
words into integers.
So we could say that
"You" corresponds to 23
and "declined" corresponds
to 45 and so on,
and this can be arbitrary.
You can choose any of them.
You just need to
save this mapping
for later so if you want to
convert the integers back
to words, you can do that.
So now we have our complaints
represented as integers.
So when we feed them
into the neural network,
we have to assign a
tensor to hold them.
And TensorFlow likes
the tensors to be fixed
sized so you can
specify them in advance.
So this means that it
will like all complaints
to be of the same length.
But in your data set,
different complaints
can be different lengths.
So to solve this,
we choose a length,
and then we make sure
everything is that length.
So if it's longer than
that, we truncate it.
If it's shorter than
that, then we pad it.
So let's say, in this
hypothetical example,
we want everything
to be 12 words long.
So this is four
short, so we add four
0's at the end, which correspond
to a pad token in the model.
But just for reference, the
actual dataset was much longer,
so the complaints were
padded to 600 words.
OK, so awesome.
After this point, our dataset is
all complaints of same length,
all of them represented
by integers.
But if you think about it,
all these integers are unique.
So we have all words
represented uniquely,
but that's not really
how our language is.
Words are not unique.
Words are related to each other.
Some words are synonyms.
Some are antonyms.
Some words are very likely
to be in similar contexts.
For example, a
king and queen are
very likely to be talked
about in the same context,
much more so than
king and AI, right?
So to get over that,
or to give the model
our understanding
of English language,
we convert each
word into a vector.
And this can be a
vector of any size.
We ended up using 128
dimensional vector.
And so what happens is that
words that are similar,
are likely to occur
in similar contexts,
have word vectors
that are closer
to each other in
the vector space.
And so this allows
us to give the model
understanding of semantics.
So to train these word vectors,
we can use two techniques.
We can train these
word vectors as part
of training the neural network.
So we initialize them
randomly, and then we
use backpropagation to train
them as we build the model.
And that's what we
did in this case.
And this allows the vectors
to have understanding
of financial terms.
The other way is
that you can actually
use pre-trained word
vectors, and these
are available on the internet.
I think GloVe is a good source
of these pre-trained vectors.
And these pre-trained
vectors have
been trained on huge
corpus of English language,
like Wikipedia and
stuff, so they are also
good at generally understanding
what context words are used in.
So Manuel will later
show a use case
where he used the
pre-trained word vectors.
OK, so now took our complaint
and we converted everything
into numbers, so we're good
to use a neural network.
So in this case, we build a
CNN for text classification.
I think a lot of you
might have heard of CNNs.
They have been quite
popular in computer vision.
They have been used
very successfully
on images for detection,
tracking, classification, et
cetera.
But more recently,
CNNs have actually
been used very successfully for
text classification as well,
and this might sound a
little bit unintuitive.
So part of the goal
of this slide for me
is to actually explain
to you the architecture
on a high level, and
also give some intuition
around why this actually works.
So maybe let's start with
a small sentence here.
"I like this movie very much."
So this is seven
words, and each word
is represented by a
five-dimensional word vector.
So you can think of
this as a 7 by 5 metric.
And at this point, you can see
it's somehow like an image,
because it becomes 2D.
And then we choose
different filters.
So we choose filters of
size two words, three words,
and four words, and they're
represented by different colors
here.
These filters will do
the convolution operation
on the sentence.
One way of thinking about this
convolution operation is--
so filter of two words will
look at two adjacent words.
Three words will
look at three words,
and then four
would look at four.
And so this is a bag of words.
So the neural network is trying
to look at adjacent words
and trying to extract
meaning from the sentence.
And then it creates
these feature maps,
which are these
one-dimensional vectors that
have summarized everything.
And you can see them
as different vectors
of different colors here.
And then finally, since
all of these feature maps
are different length,
to actually use them
in the neural network,
we do a hacky fix
where we do a 1D max pooling.
We take the maximum value from
each of these feature maps
and combine them to create
this colored vector at the end.
So the way I think of
all of this operation
is the neural network has-- the
CNN has gone over the sentence
and extracted all the
relevant information
and combined that into
that colored vector, which
is the output from this stage.
So I want to summarize the model
once more before I move on.
So we started with raw
text of complaints.
We did pre-processing
that converted the text
into integers.
Then we converted all the word
integers into word vectors.
We built the CNN.
In our actual CNN, we use
four different filter sizes
of two words, three words,
four words, and five words.
We do the concatenation.
And then the final
layer in the model
is a fully-connected layer
with sigmoid activation.
And what this does
is it assigns--
it basically assigns
each complaint
into one of the
seven departments,
assigning them
different probabilities.
And we can just
pick the department
with the highest probability as
the prediction from the model.
So as you can see, this is a
relatively simple architecture,
and it's amazing
how well this works.
So we were able to get
85% accuracy in correctly
predicting department
on the test set, which
is the set that the
model wasn't exposed
to at the time of training.
Other big benefits
here were the model
is actually quite
quick to train.
So it took only about 15
minutes of training time
on a single GPU.
Since it's so quick to
train, it's very easy
to do tuning of
hyperparameters or testing
on different architectures.
It runs pretty fast at
inference time as well,
so we're available to use
a CPU at inference time,
and that's what we will show
in the demo as well, right now.
It can also be
re-trained periodically.
So let's say you roll
out with this model
and you use it for three months
and you collect new real data
in the field, you can
easily plant that back in
and re-train the model.
And then finally, I think
a more subtle but actually
pretty important point is
because this model uses
deep learning, you don't really
need to do any complex feature
engineering.
The model itself
extracts features,
which means that
you don't need to be
an expert in financial
services, and you also
don't need to get an
LP expert to use this.
This, in my opinion, makes
deep learning very versatile.
Same architecture can be
applied on different problems
and different domains--
legal and financial
services, wherever
you want to apply them.
OK, so we have talked
a lot about the model,
so now I want to
actually do a demo of it.
Let's see if I can
switch screens.
OK, this is awesome.
So what we did is we
designed a web demo.
So this demo allows us to
interact with the model
more easily.
So in this first
page of the demo,
we have the customer's
name, phone number,
and address, which is
arbitrary at this point,
because the actual data had
this information anonymized.
And then in this
section right here
is where we can
put in a complaint,
and then when we run
it, this complaint
is run against the
CNN at the back.
So the complaint that I've
chosen is an interesting one.
It says, "I'm in the process of
refinancing with Quicken Loans.
It's been over 45
days, and I still
don't have a closing date.
They keep giving
me the run around,
and it's been nothing
but a headache."
So what I personally
find interesting
about this complaint is there
is no mention of any department
here, and it's actually a
very small complaint as well.
So if you're not familiar with
the financial services domain,
it might be hard for
you to know what product
is being talked about here.
And that, I think, is the whole
benefit of deep learning--
is just by looking at a
whole bunch of complaints,
it has understood what
are the key terms involved
with each product, and
it's then able to use that.
So now when I hit submit,
the neutral network
runs in the backend and
actually assigns this
to the Mortgage Department,
which is correct.
So besides actually predicting
the department, which
is what the case-routing
would help with,
we also have, here, what
we call the smart report.
So this report has a lot
of interesting insights.
So from the text
in the complaint,
we are able to create
this word cloud, which has
the key words in the complaint.
We are also able to
give a sentiment index--
sentiment score--
to this complaint.
We can extract
organizations and categories
that are being talked about.
As well as we are able to look
into our historical database
for other similar
complaints and present that
to the agent who's actually
working this complaint.
And that can be
pretty useful, right?
So if you're working
on this complaint,
you might want to know
what was done in the past,
and you can apply a
similar resolution.
So in the next part
of this presentation,
we want to go and talk
about how we actually
created this smart report.
Switch back.
OK, so I'm going to
now talk about how
we use the Google Language API.
So before I start,
by show of hands,
can I know how many of you
have used the Google Language
API before?
OK, that's good to know.
So those of you who
haven't, I would actually
encourage you to try it out.
It's pretty simple to use.
So the home page for
the Natural Language API
has a section where
you can use it easily.
You don't really need to
code in Python to do this.
So that's what I
want to do now, is
I want to actually
showcase the web page where
you can use the Language API.
So I clicked right into and went
into the Natural Language API
home page.
And within here, there is
the option to try the API.
So I picked a
sample sentence that
says, "ABC Bank has associated
my number with someone else's
delinquent account.
They're calling me
every hour and will not
remove my number from the
other person's account."
So this person is
clearly stressed.
So when I hit Analyze,
essentially what would happen
is that the Language
API would go and extract
information and share that
with me across four tabs.
So there's Entity, Sentiment,
Syntax, and Categories.
The Entities portion of the
API looks at things like,
hey, what's an organization?
What's a person?
What's an event?
And stuff like that and
presents that information.
The Sentiment tab gives
me a sentiment score
for the entire text, as well as
for each individual sentence.
So it has correctly
assigned this sentence
a slightly negative
sentiment, which is true.
And then for each
individual sentence,
there's a sentiment score.
What I find very,
very interesting
here is that if you look at
the second sentence, which
says, "They're
calling me every hour
and will not remove my number
from the other person's
account," there's actually no
real big negative word here,
but the model has
correctly understood
that the overall sentiment
here is pretty negative.
And I would have
actually done the same.
I would have assigned this
sentence a pretty negative
sentiment score.
So the API also has very, very
rich information about syntax.
So this has things
like part of speech.
What words are noun,
verbs, adverbs, et cetera?
It also has
dependency maps, which
can show you visually how words
are related to each other.
So you can use this to
very quickly understand
what are the verbs
in your sentence,
and then do analysis after that.
And then finally, it
also has categories.
So for us, it's very generic.
It says, these complaints are
related to financial services
and banking, which is true.
But I think this feature can
be very useful if your data
set has complaints of
many different types,
and then it can
actually tell you
what the relevant categories
are quite accurately,
and will be useful.
OK, so now I want
to hand it back over
to Manuel, who will walk you
through how we use the Language
API in our demo.
MANUEL AMUNATEGUI:
Thank you, Priya.
So Priya gave us a good overview
of what the Google Language
API is all about, and I want
to dive a little bit deeper
into how we used it
in the smart report.
It's a very powerful tool.
I think these are pre-trained
models in the Cloud.
So whenever you can, use
anything that's pre-trained--
whether an image modeling,
transfer learning,
and using pre-trained
word vectors in NLP--
or tools like these
pre-trained models.
Google offers many of
them, not just a language.
There's vision.
There's video.
There's translation.
There's transcription.
All sorts of really cool tools.
Whenever you can push that
work onto other people who
specialize on that, it's a win.
That allows you to focus you
and your team on the business
use case and leverage these
tools that work really well--
and are probably harder for
us to replicate as well.
And it frees up a lot
of time on our end.
So the smart case report--
this portion of the report
is fueled, is powered
by the Language API.
And I'm going to walk
you through a few things.
So the word cloud is
interesting, right?
It's been used a lot
in educational tools,
but it's also very
powerful in terms
of highlighting word
frequencies-- which words are
used the most.
It's very visual.
You don't have to worry too much
about the way it's presented.
It's going to
present it for you.
It will show the largest
words in a larger font
and everything else smaller.
But it doesn't have
to be frequency.
It can be anything
you want, right?
You can program this.
You could do, for
example, part of speech,
which Priya was showing
us, by the action verbs.
"I want," "I need."
That would be, also, useful in
terms of quickly figuring out
what a piece of text is about.
They're very easy to implement.
You can program them in
all sorts of languages--
through REST calls,
through Python.
It's just a call to the API.
Oh, and also, the
sentiment index, right?
It's a number between, I
think, negative 1 and 1, right?
And here we present it in a
linear scale with emoticons
from very unhappy to very happy.
In a fraction of a
second, you quickly
know the tone of the email.
So very powerful, especially if
you're doing customer service.
The topics-- so those are also
referred to as categories.
There is a category
and a subcategory.
Currently there's,
I think, last time I
read, about 700
categories it supports.
And the financial world
does a really good job
at differentiating it,
because as you saw,
our seven departments are
pretty closely related.
It still tells the difference
between all sorts of things,
very powerful.
And a nice thing about using
these Cloud-based, pre-trained
models is it's 700 right now.
And you can go to sleep and
when you wake up in the morning,
suddenly it's 1,000 categories,
or 10,000 categories, right?
So you automatically benefit
from better pre-trained model
without having to worry
about it, because you're just
calling the API.
The organization's
also really cool.
It will pull all
sorts of the entities.
It can pull famous
locations, I think locations;
in this case, organizations.
So really smart to pull
these kind of things
and quickly tell the
person or the agent that's
taking care of this, who
are the major players
in this complaint?
And now I want to talk about
pulling similar complaints that
were resolved in the past.
So there are different ways
you can approach this problem.
We thought we had a
pretty clever one here.
And the idea is that you
have an incoming case--
an incoming complaint,
for this dataset--
and you want to know what have
other agents done in the past,
and how have they
resolved it, right?
So not only is that going to
be a lot of help for the agent,
it's also a step closer to
doing auto replies, right?
Once you know how this works
well, you can determine-- well,
I think the machine leaning
can handle this automatically.
Let's just fire off a reply.
So you have this original
complaint that comes.
Let's imagine it
has 20 words, right?
So you have these 20 words.
It's hard to fish in
the entire knowledge
base of historical
complaints that we've
dealt with in the past and
finding a similar one, right?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to use pre-trained,
word-embedded vectors to boost
the vocabulary, right?
So Priya talked a bit about it.
What is a pre-trained,
word-embedded vectors?
So GloVe is a
really popular one.
They have taken either
Wikipedia as a corpus
of the English language,
or even Common Crawl,
which is a certain percentage
of the entire internet,
and modeled it to figure out
exactly how each word relates
to each other word.
So in the end, it's
very complex modeling.
So that's why we're very happy
somebody else did it for us.
And in the end,
you have a matrix
with all the most commonly
spoken English words,
and a long array of numbers.
And these numbers for each word
represent how one word relates
to another, and that's how
you can get the king to queen
is a man to woman.
It understands that.
There's basically a
mathematical underlying
to the English language
that's captured
in these pre-trained
word vectors.
And if anybody has
worked with Word2vec
and has pre-trained their
own corpuses, it's not easy.
It takes a lot of time.
You got to have the
right equipment.
And you've got to tune
it correctly, right?
Otherwise you got to go
back and do everything.
I did that a lot in health
care, and it was a lot of work.
And we didn't have GPUs,
so it was sometimes a week
to two weeks of work, right?
Just to find out that
you made a mistake
and you have to do it again.
Very frustrating.
So this is phenomenal that
they make these available.
GloVe is from Stanford.
I think Stanford and GloVe
are working together.
Stanford's maintaining
the GloVe datasets.
And they're open source.
Anybody can use them.
So what we're doing,
we're basically
taking every word of
that original complaint--
let's pretend there's 20 words.
And we'll zoom into one
word-- the word "transaction."
So then you can say, using
this pre-trained matrix,
find me all the words
that are close to the word
"transaction."
And because you have
this complex matrix that
represents how each word
relates to every other word,
you can use any distance
metric you want--
Euclidean distance,
cosine distance.
It doesn't matter.
And basically, you've created
an electronic, very powerful
thesaurus, right?
So instead of having just
the word "transaction,"
you can boost it to buying,
business, contract agreement,
or even hundreds of words.
So you do that for all
your important words--
not just ignore your stop
words, all your important words.
So you take that case that
has 20 words originally,
and now you can have
10,000 words, right?
And you can go fishing--
basically a big bag
of words-- and you
can go fishing into
your knowledge base,
and finding the most related,
the closely related cases
to bring to the surface.
Of course, you've got
to weigh the words.
You got to do a little
bit of normalization,
otherwise the very
large historical cases
would take precedence, and
you don't want that, right?
So there's a little
bit more work involved,
but that's the overall idea.
So then you basically--
I'm going to repeat
what I just said.
You're going to go with
that huge bag of words--
instead of 20, now it's
1,000-- and pull similar cases.
So that has three
distinct advantages
that are pretty powerful.
For starters, you can
now find historical cases
that don't intersect--
that have no words
at all intersecting with the
new incoming case, right?
Because you buffered that
with a new vocabulary,
they could have
no word in common,
and you can still pull them out.
The second one is there's
no training on our end.
We're not modeling
this on our end,
because we're piggybacking on
the pre-trained word vectors,
right?
So all that work is pushed
on to somebody else.
We don't have to do
any pre-training.
That saves us a lot of time.
And the third advantage,
which is related to this,
is that because we're
not doing a pre-training,
we don't have to waste any of
our own knowledge base data--
our own historical case
data-- for training.
We can then use
the entire corpus
to find similar complaints,
going all the way
from the first complaint ever
entered in your data warehouse,
to the one that maybe it
was resolved 2 seconds ago.
If it's similar, we can
find it, and we can pull it.
So we have access to
your entire corpus.
That's pretty powerful.
I'm going to do a demo as well.
So I have a simple case here.
"I'm having issues with my bank.
I have been late
on two payments,
and I can't get in
touch with anybody
to work on some kind
of repayment plan.
I'll be upset if this ends
up hurting my credit score."
So I'll run this.
So the top of that, right?
So it's saying credit reporting,
which is correct, right?
That sounds about right.
The original case is there.
You have the information
from whom that came from,
and you have the
sentiment index.
So more or less correct.
It's slightly
negative to neutral.
And the word cloud says
"issues with the bank,"
and even the word "late."
So off the bat, you know
exactly what the case is.
This becomes way more useful if
the case is very long, right?
Because you'll really
see things pop out.
It says topic is finance.
And I purposely didn't
put a bank name in there,
so it just says Bank
as the organization.
So that's acceptable here.
And then we see the
similar complaints, right?
So there are complaints
that are extremely long.
And what I like here
is that it's not
pulling anything too large.
So we know that it is looking
at not only the similar words,
but also weighing it correctly.
And we see everything is
related to a repayment plan.
You see "can't repay my loan."
"Can't repay my loan."
"Dealing with my lender."
"Need information
about my loan,"
or "struggling to
repay the loan."
And you'll see this
is not helping.
Worried about their credit
score being affected.
Here it is.
I picked one, here.
Late.
So I mean, they're all related
to the query in question,
right?
And they're all very different,
but they're similar, right?
So that's what's
really interesting
about this approach.
And there's Word2vec
and there's Doc2vec.
I don't know if you've
heard of these terms.
This is more paragraph
to vec, right?
Maybe we'll make it
into a final product
where you can take a paragraph
and find a similar paragraph
by adding extra
weighting, by adding
all these kind of things.
So I'll close this
by saying two things.
And I'm seeing the people
raising their hands.
I think we're all
on the same page.
There are two things
that are really great
right now in natural language
processing-- in my opinion.
I've worked in natural
processing for the past 10
years, and I've seen
such a progression.
Two enormous boons to our work--
one is having access to
these pre-trained word
vectors, right?
This is huge.
GloVe is one.
There are tons of other ones.
You have them for
all major languages,
and you'll have them for
specialized languages--
legal, medical.
People have gone
through the painstaking
work of modeling huge corpuses
of different languages
and made them available,
have released them
in the public domain
for us to work.
So I encourage anybody who
needs-- unless you need really,
really specialized,
rare dialects
or rare technical
language, use them.
It's probably better than
anything we can come up with.
These are usually PhD
students who work on it.
They do it really well.
We should leverage that work,
and it's there for us to use.
The second-- so Word2vec was
definitely a big one, right?
But the pre-trained word
vector's even better, right?
Because you don't have
to do it yourself.
And the second thing that
was really a real boon
to natural language
processing is feeding language
into convolutional
neural networks.
Like Priya talked
about, CNNs seem
to do anything these
days-- time series,
natural language processing,
along with images and sound,
these kinds of things
that it does normally.
It does it really well.
And a huge advantage is a lot
of the feature engineering
is done automatically
by the neural network.
You don't have to
worry about it.
And as we get
better at this, it's
going to get a lot better than
any feature engineering we
can come up with as humans.
We do have a GitHub.
It's not currently open.
We were focusing on getting
this presentation done.
We're going to
clean up the code,
and then we'll publish
every one of these parts,
but maybe in three separate
code bases in this GitHub
repository.
If you want access,
please email us.
If you want access before
that, please email us.
Also, the link to
the demo is there.
That also will be
open for a bit.
We may close it after a while.
And you have the
link to SpringML,
and Priya's and
my email address.
So if you have
questions about this--
it doesn't have to be about
case-routing or anything
natural language processing,
or even anything CNNs--
we'd love to help out.
We'd love to get involved.
If your organization
needs help there,
we also would be
happy to get involved.
So we're going to open
it up for questions.
If there's any questions,
please, you can ask them.
And we'll be around
afterwards as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]